Вітаю на уроці геометрії сьомого класу.
Переходимо до властивості бісектриси.
Кожна точка бісектриси кута
рівновіддалена від сторін даного кута.
Що це означає?
Якщо ми маємо певний кут та його
бісектрису, яка ділить його навпіл
і ми візьмемо якісь
точки, наприклад, A та D -
то відстані від цих точок до
даного кута будуть однаковими.
Тобто АС = АВ,
відповідно DЕ = DF.
Відстань – це перпендикуляр,
опущений з точки на сторону кута.
Давайте доведемо цю властивість.
Маємо певну бісектрису кута, отже
кут С і позначено будь-яку точку, точку А.
Опустимо перпендикуляр
з точки А на сторони кута.
Потрібно довести, що дані
два відрізки будуть рівними.
Якщо це довільна точка А, то
зараз ми наведемо доведення.
Якщо це сама точка С –
то доведення є очевидним,
оскільки вона лежить на перетині сторін
кута і відповідно буде рівновіддалена.
Доведення. Нехай перпендикуляри
опускаються у точки К та L.
Отримали два трикутники, ΔАLС та ΔАКС,
які є прямокутними,
з прямими кутами L та К.
За ознакою рівності трикутників
маємо гіпотенуза АС є спільною,
відповідно кут АСL = куту КСА,
як рівні, оскільки бісектриса СА.
З ознаки рівності прямокутних трикутників
ми маємо два рівних трикутники.
Ознака буде формулюватись
за гіпотенузою та гострим кутом.
Оскільки трикутники рівні –
отримали рівність інших елементів,
а саме рівність катетів, АL=АК.
Властивість доведено.
Переходимо до поняття
вписаного кола у трикутник.
Отже, коло називають вписаним у трикутник,
якщо воно дотикається до усіх його сторін.
Зображення ми можемо бачити на слайді
Кожна сторона трикутника
є дотичною до даного кола.
Звідси випливає теорема, що в
будь-який трикутник можна вписати коло.
Давайте її доведемо.
Для доведення цієї теореми
достатньо знайти таку точку,
яка буде рівновіддалена
від усіх його сторін,
що і відповідатиме нашому центру кола.
Буде центр, який матиме довжини,
у вигляді радіусів до наших сторін.
Давайте знайдемо цю точку.
Є трикутник.
За властивістю бісектриси кута вона
буде рівновіддалена від його сторін.
Якщо ми проведемо бісектриси двох кутів,
то точка їх перетину буде
рівновіддалена від усіх трьох сторін.
Отримали дві бісектриси,
точка О - точка перетину.
За властивістю бісектриси т.О
буде віддалена від сторін цього кута,
та т.О буде віддалена
від сторін даного кута,
цей перпендикуляр ми вже маємо.
Отримали точку, яка однаково
віддалена від усіх трьох сторін,
що доводить – це буде центр кола.
Також ця теорема має два
певні наслідки і один з них –
що всі три бісектриси відповідно будуть
перетинатись в одній єдиній точці,
це точка О
і те, що центр кола,
вписаного у трикутник,
належить точці перетину бісектрис.
Маємо два наслідки з теореми.
Наслідок один. Бісектриси кутів
трикутника перетинаються в одній точці.
Наслідок два. Центр кола,
вписаного в трикутник,
- це точка перетину
бісектрис даного трикутника.
Розв`язання задач.
Задача 1. Доведіть, що центр вписаного
кола рівнобедреного трикутника
належить висоті,
проведеній до його основи.
Маємо центр кола, вписаного
у рівнобедрений трикутник.
За нашою теоремою ми можемо
вписати коло в даний трикутник
і за наслідком з теореми, ми маємо,
що цей центр має належати
точці перетину бісектрис.
Маємо коло і рівнобедрений ΔАВС,
сторони АВ і ВС будуть рівними.
За властивістю ми маємо, що точка
О центр належить перетину бісектрис.
ВО, СО, АО - бісектриси
відповідних кутів.
За властивістю рівнобедреного
трикутника ми маємо,
що бісектриса проведена з вершини
трикутника буде її висотою та медіаною
ВО – є висотою та медіаною
за властивістю рівнобедреного трикутника.
Задачу розв`язано.
Пропоную розв`язати таку ж
саму задачу, але навпаки – доведіть,
що коли центр вписаного кола
трикутника належить висоті,
то цей трикутник рівнобедрений.
Наступна задача.
Коло, вписане в трикутник АВС,
дотикається до його сторін АВ, ВС і АС
у точках М,К,Е відповідно.
ВК = 2 см, КС = 4 см, АМ = 8 см.
Знайдіть периметр трикутника АВС.
Маємо коло, вписане в ΔАВС.
Воно доторкається до сторін АВ, ВС, АС в
точках М, К, Е (умови задачі на екрані).
Запишемо коротку умову.
Маємо ВК = 2 см,
відповідно
КС = 4 см
та АМ = 8 см.
Умови задачі на дошці.
Для того, щоб розв`язати задачу –
маємо згадати властивості дотичної.
Сторони нашого трикутника
є дотичними до кола.
Сторони нашого трикутника перетинаються у
певних точках, які називаються вершинами.
Виходить, що ми маємо по дві
пари дотичних з кожної вершини.
З властивості дотичних –
відрізки дотичних, проведених
з однієї точки, будуть рівними.
Отже, за властивості дотичних маємо,
для вершини В
ВМ = ВК як відрізки дотичних,
проведених з однієї точки.
звідси: ВМ=ВК = 2 см
Відповідно аналогічним чином
визначаємо, що КС = CE = 4 см;
та АМ = АЕ = 8 см.
Отримали всі складові даного трикутника,
і просумувавши певні відрізки
отримати периметр трикутника.
Відповідно, 2 + 4 = 6 см - одна сторона;
4 + 8 = 12 см – друга сторона;
2 + 8 = 10 см – третя сторона.
Периметр трикутника = 6 + 12 + 10 = 28 см.
Завдяки властивості дотичних,
ми змогли віднайти відрізки,
на які поділяє наше коло
сторони даного трикутника.
Наступна задача.
Потрібно довести, що радіус кола,
вписаного в прямокутний трикутник,
буде дорівнювати (а + b - с)/2,
де r – радіус вписаного кола,
а і b – катети, с – гіпотенуза.
Маємо прямокутний трикутник
та вписане коло в даний трикутник.
Позначимо катети як а та b,
нашу гіпотенузу – с,
центр кола – точка О, радіус - r.
Потрібно довести формулу: (а+в-с)/2 =r.
Проведемо з точки О радіуси у
точку дотику. Що ми отримаємо?
Ми отримаємо два перпендикуляри,
оскільки за властивістю дотичних,
радіус, проведений у точку дотику,
буде перпендикулярний до дотичної.
Ми маємо два перпендикуляри.
З`єднаємо точку О та вершину прямокутного
трикутника саме в прямому куті.
Ми маємо за властивістю
кола, вписаного в трикутник,
що центр кола лежить
на перетині бісектрис.
Даний відрізок поєднання нашого
центру та прямого кута буде бісектрисою.
А це означає, що це
бісектриса прямого кута,
тобто ділить його на
два кути по 45 градусів.
В цьому прямокутному трикутнику
давайте позначимо вершини літерами С, А, В
відповідно в прямокутному
трикутнику ОС та точка Н,
ми маємо дві однакові сторони,
тобто два однакових катети. Чому?
Тому що кут 45 градусів – буде кутом ОСН,
знаходимо за сумою трикутників третій кут,
відповідно він буде теж 45 градусів
(45 градусів + 45 градусів = 90 градусів
та плюс 90 градусів = 180 градусів).
Трикутник ОСН – рівнобедрений трикутник.
Катет ОН, який є радіусом, дорівнюватиме
катету СН, який теж буде радіусом.
Позначимо другу точку
дотику - М та третю – L.
За властивістю рівності дотичних,
маємо певну пару відрізків дотичних –
СН = СМ = r.
Це за властивістю відрізків дотичних.
Аналогічним чином – ВН = ВL.
Позначимо ВН, як а-r.
Якщо ми маємо СН – це r, весь
катет СВ буде дорівнювати а.
Відповідно ВН = а–r = ВL.
Аналогічним чином
визначаємо частини АМ та АL,
які відповідно дорівнюватимуть
b - r, як рівні відрізки дотичних.
Отримали дві частини, на які поділяє
точка дотику нашого вписаного кола,
нашу гіпотенузу, а саме ВL та АL.
Сумуючи їх, ми отримаємо
гіпотенузу, яка дорівнює с.
Давайте запишемо.
Роблячи алгебраїчні перетворення та
перенісши катети а і b у праву частину
і поділивши весь вираз на -2,
отримаємо таку рівність:
-2r = (с – а – b)/(-2).
Отримаємо r = (а + b– с)/2,
що і потрібно було довести.
Отже, радіус вписаного кола у прямокутний
трикутник визначається за формулою –
r= (а + b – с )/2
Наступна задача.
Точка дотику вписаного кола
рівнобедреного трикутника
ділить його бічну сторону у відношенні
7:5, рахуючи від вершини трикутника.
Знайдіть сторони даного трикутника,
якщо його периметр дорівнює 68 см.
Маємо коло та рівнобедрений трикутник.
Вершини трикутника як
А, В, С; точки дотику – К, L, М.
За умовою, наша бічна сторона,
ділиться у відношенні 7 до 5,
рахуючи від вершини.
Можемо позначити відрізки, на які поділяє
точка дотику нашу бічну сторону,
як 7х та 5х.
Запишемо умову.
Периметр даного трикутника дорівнює
68 см, і даний трикутник є рівнобедреним.
Використовуючи властивості дотичних, маємо
певну кількість пар рівних відрізків,
на які поділяє точки дотику
сторони нашого трикутника.
Згадуючи, що трикутник є рівнобедреним,
і за його властивістю маємо,
що бічні сторони будуть рівними.
Отже, якщо ми поділили
сторону ВС на відрізки 7х та 5х,
то сторона АВ буде поділятись
на такі самі два відрізки – 7х та 5х.
За властивістю дотичної отримаємо,
що наша основа має два відрізки,
які будуть рівні відповідним
відрізкам бічних сторін.
тобто КА = АМ.
Відповідно, якщо ми маємо КА = 5х,
то і отримаємо в основі
частинку 5х - то частинка АМ.
Тоді якщо LC = 5х, то МС
аналогічним чином дорівнюватиме 5х.
КВ залишається 7х.
Можна було і не використовувати
властивість рівнобедреного трикутника,
точніше його означення, що бічні
сторони рівні, а, наприклад, відрізок КВ
знайти за відповідно властивістю
дотичних, що ці два відрізки рівні.
А точка М – це є точка, яка
ділить сторону АС навпіл,
тому що ВМ, який проходить через центр
кола є бісектрисою, висотою та медіаною.
Але можна і використати
означення рівнобедреного трикутника.
Перейдемо до розрахунків.
Дивимось на екран розв`язок.
Дивимось на дошку та записуємо:
5х + 5х + 5х + 7х + 5х + 7х = 68;
34х = 68
х = 2
Сторони нашого трикутника
будуть 10х (де х = 2), відповідно 20.
Та по 12х – відповідно по 24. Отримали
відповідь – 20 см, 24 см та 24 см.
Мали б записати, що
за властивістю дотичних,
наші відрізки АМ та АК були б
рівними, та СМ = СL, тоді 5х = 5х.
Та за означенням рівнобедреного
трикутника бічні сторони були б рівними,
тоді ми могли б скласти
рівняння, яке ми розв`язали.
Перейдемо до наступної задачі.
Маємо трикутник з кутами 30
градусів, 70 градусів та 80 градусів.
Потрібно знайти кути трикутника,
утвореного точками дотику
вписаного кола в даний трикутник.
Маємо коло та ΔАВС.
Кут А = 30 градусів, кут С = 70
градусів та кут В = 80 градусів.
І маємо три точки дотику – F, Е, D.
Поєднуємо точки дотику і
отримуємо трикутник DЕF.
Потрібно знайти кути даного трикутника.
Запишемо умову.
Давайте розглянемо один окремий кут
та спробуємо знайти, щось, знаючи цей кут,
тоді для двох інших буде
відповідно аналогічним.
Позначимо в якості точки О
центр нашого вписаного кола.
Поєднаємо т.О з точками
дотику та з нашим кутом А.
Отримуємо радіуси ОD, ОF та ОА.
Дивимось на екран.
ОА за властивістю кола є бісектриса,
оскільки центр кола
лежить у перетині бісектрис.
Отже, можемо вказати,
що кут ОАD = 15 градусів.
ОD – радіус, проведений у точку дотику.
ОD буде перпендикулярним до
дотичної АС, кут ОDС або ОDА –
90 градусів, є прямим.
Тепер ми можемо знайти
кут АОD, за сумою кутів.
який дорівнюватиме тут 15,
тут 90, за сумою кутів трикутника:
180 – 90 – 15 = 75 градусів.
Отже, АО – бісектриса
у рівнобедреному трикутнику FAD,
оскільки це два рівні відрізки дотичних,
то тоді вона є медіаною
і висотою до відрізка FD.
Тут кут 90 градусів, то за
сумою сторін трикутника,
у трикутнику ОD точка перетину
Н, отримаємо що частинка кута ODH
= 15 градусів.
Кут ОDН = 180 – 90 – 75 = 15 градусів.
Аналогічним чином визначається кут OFH,
який також дорівнюватиме 15 градусів
Оскільки трикутник FOD – є рівнобедреним,
у нього дві сторони є радіусами.
Аналогічним чином, за допомогою таких
самих побудов, а саме радіус у точку Е
та бісектрис з точки С
та точки В, можемо знайти
інші частини кутів нашого трикутника FDE.
Кут OED = 35 градусів, дивимось на дошку.
Оскільки тут 70, то ми
знаходимо тут половинка 35,
тут 90 і аналогічні міркування
– отримаємо, що ці кути по 35.
Аналогічним чином отримаємо,
що дані кути будуть по 40 градусів.
Ці частинки кутів, які
утворилися при даних побудовах,
дорівнюють половинці нашого кута,
тобто тут 30 градусів, тут по 15 градусів;
Якщо кут С =70 градусів,
то по 35 градусів,
якщо кут В 80 градусів –
тоді там по 40 градусів.
Отже, кути нашого трикутника FED
знаходяться, як сума цих двох частинок.
Відповідно, кут Е = 75 градусів.
Кут F = 40 + 15 = 55 градусів.
Та кут D = 35 + 15 = 50 градусів.
Запишемо відповідь.
Ми знайшли кути трикутника, який утворився
якщо поєднати вершини наших точок дотику,
вписаного кола до даного трикутника.
На наступному занятті ми будемо
розглядати описане коло навколо трикутника
і відповідно де буде
лежати центр нашого кола.
А сьогодні урок завершено.
Я бажаю вам успіхів та дякую за увагу.